[Applaudissements]
trois choses si vous trouvez face à un
objet qu'on a de plus en plus
trois règles d'or déjà quand vous
arrivez face à l'ours le lourd ça arrive
l'ours va essayer de vous attraper avec
ses griffes comme ceci là
j'écarte
ça arrive comme ceci là j'écarte la
grille comme ceci comme ceci et là je
l'attrape
aux ailes
et là tu lui parles qu'est-ce que tu as
voulu faire
jamais et un ours qui commence à vous
bousiller et tout vous dites rien je dis
non c'est marrant c'est le moins d'être
humain qui vous parle vous lui mettez
une baffe un animal non franchement non
je vous jure je ne pourrai pas frapper
un animal même une rien même un lion une
raie je vois ce que je peux si je peux
faire quelque chose
que j'essaie de leur parler
tuer c'est une des machines
qui qui émettent
l'odeur de l'homme exactement et donc
elle part dans la direction qu'elle
parte dans les trucs elles vont dans les
machines elles restent là-bas en fait
les moustiques sont devant la machine
l'odeur de l'homme tout ça j'ai pas ça
mais tu sais ce qu'il faut acheter stop
insectes
pardon c'est sur TF1 mais qu'est-ce que
ça marche
vraiment quoi vraiment moi j'ai jeté
deux trucs ça et la chaufferette
hivernale c'est les deux trucs
hivernale c'est un tout petit truc que
tu mets près de ton lit ou quoi c'est
très pratique vous avez vu ça bon je
m'emmerdais un matin
je dis voilà j'aime pas les rats mais je
frappe après caméra
[Rires]